I love movies that make me wonder what
would I do in that situation so the only
place and with this one is if you guys
in real life inherit of the house and
found a whole bunch of money in it would
you even hesitate or would you just keep
it for sure okay I'm just scared of
breaking rules period that's just a part
of my personality I like to do things by
the book so I don't know I mean in a way
I'm like I feel like I should because
it's like where else is this money gonna
go you know if he has no family you're
gonna go to the government know like
it's gonna you know it should go to me
like I had a man but knowing myself in
the moment I'd get a chicken I'd be too
scared I keep at least some anything I
might distribute it amongst family and
friends so we all like share the blame
you know I found a hundred thousand I'm
gonna do 20 yeah I'm gonna give you 20
mom you keep this 20 you know that no
one's ever gonna come check your closet
just in case mine gets taken whatever I
would I would divide it up I'm a big
baby so I probably wouldn't have been
able to sleep at night so even though I
know it probably wouldn't been that big
of a deal I would pass on it but I'm a
sucker I was it ever difficult for you
guys keeping the mystery alive while you
run said you knew the entire story from
start to finish and then on top of that
I'd like to bake you're not shooting the
story in sequence so was it ever kind of
difficult to make it seem like her
character had no clue what was going on
it was I mean the thing is I actually
even though I had read the script so
many times I still would struggle Bayley
what's happening here and why is that
over right like we had to constantly be
revisiting the story in the plot to kind
of remind ourselves what's going on and
in a way it helps because then it felt
like I really sometimes was like I
really don't know where this is going
even though I actually know it was it
wasn't extremely accessible at my mind
all the time no I agree it was a very
complex story and because we shoot it
out of sequence you know there's a lot
of things I was like okay I don't know
where I am at this time
what what I know you know as the
character I don't know what cami knows
so it was nice to be able to go back and
forth about that she know that I know
that he right yeah there was a lot of
this is a lot of them but does she know
that I know she knows what she doesn't
know confusing would you guys say that
was the biggest new challenge maybe you
faced in making this movie or is there
anything you know character wise or
production wise that was a first time
and it's up time for you being on
Riverdale feel like I'm pretty used to
complex you know mystery story lines so
that part you know a lot of times on
Riverdale I've also am like wait what
happens again so um so no I think that
part was pretty familiar if anything
what felt different or the most the
different the most defining moment I
guess for this project that really set
it apart was the challenge of having to
experience my husband's death in the
movie while also kind of wrapping up the
mystery you know so it's like that
emotional climax mixed with this like
mystery exposition so playing those two
at the same time was very challenging
you have to watch that whole scene play
out from like being dead on the on the
in the hallway watched at all
so do I dare ask what the secret is of
playing dead are you just literally
laying there the entire time that
they're shooting that shot at least over
and over and over it is the hardest
thing to do on set I would rather spend
a month everyday just balling tears and
like really overly emotional stuff then
to try to lay there for a whole scene in
play day cuz everything is funny
all of a sudden yeah and all of a sudden
you can't concentrate on anything else
other than your breathing you don't you
think you're breathing too hard and then
you're not breathing enough so you're
getting lightheaded like this is so much
that happens when you're trying to play
there you came already jesse is like a
very giggly person like as soon as he I
am oh he can't stop like it takes a
minute to laugh at all Jen you lying
down dead
keep it together and everything is funny
like if your shoe lace comes untied it's
the funniest thing imaginable when
you're trying to be dead like it sucks
and so hard you put something in your
head like that I've got the same problem
I can't handle it we're just going for
spoilers now and I kind of love it so
things that I really wanted to ask you
is that Katie's wrestling with the
decision of whether or not to keep the
money the entire film at the end when
she finds out that the will isn't real
do you think she ever had to kind of
wrestle with the decision whether to
keep the house after that or had that
ship sailed
um I think by the end I think in her
mind it's like well I deserve this like
after all the craziness that happened
and like and you know and even Julia
said there's no one to contest it
there's no one around to be like no you
can't take this house so really it's
hers for the taking
okay I think it's pretty reasonable and
you think that she really didn't know
where the diamonds were did she not hear
him say Garten and if that is the case
is she going to find them do you think
you know we've been asked this question
a lot and the more I get asked the more
I start to change my answer I liked
playing it that she didn't know and in a
way like didn't didn't care but just
like considering how much drama there
was around those diamonds um I think the
idea of finding them and like whatever
that might bring and whatever
responsibilities it might follow I think
is a pretty scary daunting thought so in
a way maybe she's totally fine not
finding the diamonds I kind of believe
she yes I think it's even stated in the
movie the money was never what mattered
to her thank you guys very much Congrats
on the movie thanks Perry